hello everyone and welcome to this data
science crash course my name is marco
and i just recently started a youtube
channel where i do videos on
data science so if you want to check it
out the link is in the description below
a bit of an overview of this crash
course we will first answer
the question what is data science then
we will walk through a setup
so that you are ready on your computers
to code along with me
and then we will move on to the
algorithms which is in my opinion
the fun part so we'll talk about linear
regression
then we will move on to classification
with logistic regression
lda and qda we will talk about
resampling and regularization methods
which are very important in any workflow
for a data scientist
we will talk about decision trees uh
most of the state-of-the-art algorithms
are actually
tree-based methods so a very exciting
subject
and then we will move on to support
vector machines
and conclude this crash course with
unsupervised
learning now let's answer this question
what is data science
well data science is a field that uses
scientific methods to extract
knowledge and insights from data now
this definition
may look very broad and that's because
data science
is a very broad field in fact it
encompasses three professions so
you can be a machine learning scientist
or engineer
which means that you are the person who
develops the algorithms
you could also be a data analyst which
is the person who answers
business questions for example what is
the product
that we sold the most in the last month
that would be
the job of the data analyst or finally
you could be a data engineer
which is the person that builds the
software to gather data from different
sources
because usually the data needed to solve
a problem
is not in the same place so those data
engineers
they gather the data from everywhere and
put it in a
format that can be used after by the
data analyst
or the machine learning engineer now
this crash course will mostly focus
on the machine learning part because we
will mostly discuss
the algorithms now what can you expect
from this course well first of all
theory yes as in math equations because
theory
is important in data science you need to
know
how a model behaves why it behaves in a
certain way
and how it works because understanding
that
is actually way harder than coding the
algorithm itself
as you will see later on also if your
goal is to land a job
as a data scientist in a company well
you will be asked
theoretical questions during the
interview so a very important part
please don't skip it
and of course each algorithm section
will be accompanied by
hands-on examples in python so for each
algorithm
we will download a data set and we will
apply this algorithm on that data set
so without further ado let's get started
with the setup
all right let's get you set up to do
some data science
head over to google and search for
anaconda
then click on the first result which
should be anaconda the world's most
popular
data science platform once you click on
it
head over to products and then
individual edition
you can read more about what anaconda is
if you want
otherwise simply click on download and
it brings you
here where you can select the installer
which is appropriate to your
operating system now in my case i have
windows
64 so it would be the graphical
installer if you're on mac or on linux
choose the one that suits you best once
you click on it you can
download and save the file now i will
not do this
since i already installed it on my
machine but once it is downloaded you
can simply
follow the instructions on the graphical
installer
and once everything is done you should
be able at least on windows
if you hit the windows key and start
typing jupiter
with a y simply type enter
and after a moment you should see this
page showing up
and that means that jupiter is installed
correctly and you're ready to do some
data science
if you're on mac however simply open
your terminal and type in
jupiter notebook with a space and you
should be fine
all right now that we are set up let's
kick off this crash course with our very
first algorithm which is
linear regression we start with a simple
linear regression
where our target y only depends on one
variable
x and a constant beta 1 is then
a parameter which can be positive or
negative that characterizes
the slope and beta naught here is the
constant
to find the parameters we need to
minimize a certain error function
so here the error is simply the
difference between the real target
y i and the prediction y hat
for linear regression we minimize the
sum of squared errors
so we raise this equation to the power
of 2 and add
all errors across all data points
visually it looks like this the red dots
represent our data
and the blue line is our fitted straight
line each vertical line
is the magnitude of the error so we want
the
to position the blue line such as the
sum
of the squared length of each vertical
line
is as small as possible now you might
wonder why do we square the errors well
as you saw the points can lie
above or below the fiddle line so the
error can be positive or negative
if we did not square the error we could
be adding a bunch of negative errors and
reduce the sum of errors
it would trick us in thinking that we
are fitting a good straight line
where in fact we're not it also has the
added advantage of penalizing large
errors
so we really get the best fit possible
for simple linear regression you can
find the parameters analytically with
these formulas where
x bar is the mean of the independent
variable and y bar is the mean of the
target
now of course in practice we will use
python to estimate those parameters for
us
here you can see we first initialized
the model and then we fit
on x and y and then we can retrieve both
the intercept and the coefficient as you
can see here
once you have your coefficients we need
a way to assess their relevancy
to do so we use the p-value this allows
us to quantify
the statistical significance and
determine if we can reject the null
hypothesis
or not in python we can analyze
the p value for each coefficient like
this
here we use a statistical package from
python that allows us to print out a
summary
of the model here you can see an example
of that summary
so for each coefficient you get here the
p-value
which is the p greater than absolute
value of t
here you see the value is zero but it is
really not zero
however it is so small that it appears
to be zero
once we know our parameters are relevant
we must assess the model itself
we usually use the residual standard
error of course
the smaller the value the better it is
since the difference between predicted
and actual
is small as you can see with the
equation on the screen
also we use the r squared value which
measures the proportion of variability
explained by a feature x as it
approaches 1 it means
that we are explaining a lot of the
variability in our target
in python we can use the same process as
we did before to find the p-value
using the same package so as you can see
when we print out the summary this is
the full printout that you get from the
python package
you see highlighted in yellow the
r-squared value
in this example now from here multiple
linear regression is easy to understand
as we simply extend the model to
accommodate
more features now each feature has its
own parameter
and p is the number of predictors
so in python we saw how to access the
constant n1 parameter and if we have
multiple parameters
then we simply increase the
index to get the other parameters
in multiple linear regression to assist
the model
of a multiple linear regression we use
the f statistic
here p is the number of predictors and n
is the number of
data points now again in python we'll
use the
same package that outputs for us the f
statistic
as you can see here in yellow the f
statistic for a multiple linear
regression
model usually if f is much
greater than one we say that there is a
strong relationship between our
predictors
and the target for a small data set of a
couple hundred data points
then we the f statistic has to be way
larger than one so that's it for the
theory of linear regression
let's see how we can apply it with
python
so let's fire up our jupyter notebooks
here i have a folder
called data which contains a data set
for this exercise
so as with any project we start off by
importing the libraries we will use so
of course we're going to use pandas as
pd let's import numpy as
np now it's time to import matplotlib
and because we will use that of course
to do some plots of our data
a lot of straight lines and scatter
plots
then we're going to use cycle learn to
actually fit a linear model
to our data set
your regression and finally we also
import
a stats library so stats models
dot api as sm
and that will give us some very cool um
statistical tests to uh test for our
predictors and model in general
and of course we use some python magic
to plot
so let's start off by importing our data
set so data is equal to pde.read.csv
i put in the path of my data so data
slash
advertising.csv and then i will specify
the
index call equal to zero
and that means that the first column
will be used as the index column in our
data set
doing data.head you should see the
following first five entries of our data
so as you can see we have
ad spend on tv radio and newspaper and
the impact on
sales so we start off with
some simple linear regression so we will
only consider the effect of
tv on sales in this case feel free to
take
radio or newspaper so i always like to
do a
quick plot of my data whenever possible
in this case because we only have one
feature one target
it is indeed possible so i first set the
size of my figure and then we do a
scatter plot
so specify the x which is going to be
data tv the y is data sales
and then i specify the color i want it
to be black
afterwards i'm just doing making my plot
uh a bit
nicer so i just specified an x label
um so there's gonna be money spent on tv
ads and the units is money such as
dollar sign
and then plt.y label is going to be
equal
actually no i do not have to put an
equal sign here i need to remove
that so remove this from this all right
perfect
and now i do this is going to be sales
and it's going to be in thousands of
dollars
perfect finally i do plt show and you
should see the following
plot there you go as you can see so this
is our data so the sales
with respect to the money spent on tp
ads now maybe a linear
line a linear regression is not the best
model here but let's try it
anyways so we're going to specify our
feature which in this case is only the
data
tv so the values are reshaped minus 1 1
as required by the scikit learn library
and then we specify the
target which is our sales values dot
reshape
minus 1 1 perfect
now we simply call the regression
model so rag is going to be equal to
linear regression
and then we will fit the model to our
data we pass in x
and y awesome and with that we can print
our parameters so we can print our
constant and coefficient for tv so the
linear model is
y is going to be equal to so first we're
gonna
access uh actually we're gonna access
the intercept
first uh so we intersect underscore
zero and then we add the
coefficient for x
so in this case tv and the coefficient
is equivalent to beta1
if you looked at the theory portion of
this video
so as you can see we get a constant of 7
and a slope of 0.0475
approximately so that's great we have a
positive slope
positive constant it seems to make sense
so let's get some predictions and
actually plot our straight line
so you can get the prediction simply by
calling the predict method
on x and then we do
another figure so i'm always again
just setting the fixed size here not
curly braces sorry about that
it's actually just normal parentheses so
put it the same size as before 16 8
then plt dot scatter we pass in
x y and of course the color is going to
be black so this is going to be our data
set
as shown uh above a bit earlier
and then we add in uh the plot of our
predations
so same x the y in this case is going to
be predictions
and i want it to be in blue and i'm
going to specify the line width
to be equal to 2 just to make sure that
we can see it
now let's just copy the labels because
it's going to be exactly the same the
same sorry
uh the plt does show as well awesome
let's run it
and boom as you can see we have ours
traded
our straight line plotted on our graph
uh that's awesome perfect so let's move
on to the next
portion where we will assess the quality
of our
uh model so to do so we're actually
gonna use
the stats library so i'm going to
re-specify again my
x and my y and we're going to fit
another linear
model but using the stats library
so specify the exogenous variable as sm
add constant x and then the estimator
is simply sm.ols that stands for
ordinary least
squares that's the method we're using
pass in y pass in x and we fit
finally you can print a summary of the
estimator
and you should see the following result
so as you can see we have an r squared
value of 0.6
so that is not very good only 60 of the
variability
is explained the s statistic is 312
which is much larger than one so it
seems that our model is
kind of good and as you can see here for
tv we get the same coefficients as
before
and the p-value although probably not
zero it seems to be
less than 0.05 so it means that our
um that our feature is indeed
relevant in this model so that was
simple linear regression let's move on
to multiple
linear regression so in this case we
will consider all the features so tv
radio and newspaper and see how that
affects the sales
so all my x's to define them i'm just
going to drop
the sales column and make sure i dropped
it
on axis equals one so i mean i'm
dropping it only the column
and on the rows and the y is going to be
the same so that is sales the values dot
reshape
minus one and one again i'm going to fit
using scikit-learn so the regressor is
linear regression
and you call fit so x's and
y perfect now as before we're going to
print our
coefficients so the linear model
is skip a line and then
y is going to be equal to
so let's start off by printing uh the
constant right so reg.intercept
underscore square bracket is zero
and then the coefficients will be in the
same order as
in the data set so the first one if i
remember well it's going to be for tv so
reg dot co f
0 0 and then
um multiply that by uh tv
afterwards we're gonna add the
coefficient
as the second one oh this is
not in the brackets sorry about that
radio and let's put all of this inside
the brackets
start the squiggly brackets right
and now we're gonna add the last
coefficient so reg dot co f
zero one two sorry
and let's bring this a bit to the right
so you can see the code
uh we multiply that by news paper
awesome let's run this cell
hopefully everything is going to work no
the regression object has no attribute
code f
indeed it does not uh we need to add an
underscore
on the coefficient of tv so coeff
underscore
awesome there you go there we have it so
uh we have two as a constant .04 so the
same slope for tv
point 18 for radio and negative for
newspaper that is very interesting we
have a negative
effect from newspaper so
again let's fi let's use the stats
library
to assess the quality of our model so
i'm just going to specify the x as
np not column stack and then we take
everything so data tv
we're gonna take uh data radio
right yes data radio
and data newspaper
awesome so this is our x our features
and the target again is data
sales
sorry shape minus one one
awesome so again the exogenous variable
we're going to do
sm.add constant we use x
we define our estimator which is sm.ols
and then passing y passing x
in this case exalt right.fit and we
print
the summary of our estimator
and you should get the following awesome
now as you can see the r squared value
is
much larger than before we have 0.897 so
we're explaining almost 90 percent of
the variability of the variability of
the sales here
the f statistic 570 again larger than
before so it means that our model is
pretty good i actually to predict the
sales from that and as you can see here
all the constants and all the
coefficients
now as you see for the last one we have
a p-value
equal to 0.860 so that is
larger than 0.05 and recall that
this coefficient here is the one for
newspaper so that means the newspaper is
actually not relevant in our model
and we could and actually we should take
it out
let's move on now to the next topic
which is classification
first a bit of terminology binary
classification is also termed
simple classification and this is the
case when we only have two classes
for example spam or not spam a
fraudulent transaction
or not of course you can also have more
than two classes
for example eye color which can be blue
green or brown
now you see in the context of
classification we have a qualitative or
categorical response unlike regression
problems where we have a
quantitative response or numbers
so now let's see how we can perform
classification
with one algorithm which is logistic
regression
ideally when doing classification we
want to determine the probability of an
observation to be part of a class
or not therefore we ideally want the
output to be between
0 and 1 where 1 means very likely
well it just turns out that there is a
function to do that and it's the sigmoid
function that you see on the screen
as you can see as x approaches infinity
you approach
one and if you go towards negative
infinity you approach
zero the sigmoid function is expressed
like this
and here we are assuming only one
predictor x
for now we stick to one predictor to
make the explanation simpler
with some manipulation you can get to
this formula here
so we are trying to get a linear
equation for x
take the log on both sides and you get
the log it
as you can see now it is linear with
respect to x
and most importantly the probability is
bound
between 0 and 1. now of course we can
extend the log it formula to accommodate
multiple predictors
this always gives better results since
you are considering
more predictors in python we can perform
classification using
logistic regression like this so again
we initialize the model first
and then we fit on our training data
passing the features
x and target y then we can get the
probability
that an observation is part of a class
once we have that probability
if it is greater than 0.5 we will say
that it is part of that class so we will
output one
otherwise it will be equal to zero which
is what the last line of this script
is doing now that's it for logistic
regression let's move on to
linear discriminant analysis or lda
now we want to learn about lda because
logistic regression has some caveats
when classes are well separated the
parameters estimate
tend to be unstable they are also
unstable when the data set is small
and finally logistic regression can only
be used for binary classification
with lda you can overcome those issues
because
it models the distribution of predictors
for each class
so you can have more than two target
classes and it does so using bae's
theorem now bae's theorem is explained
like this
suppose that we want to classify an
observation into one of
capital k classes where capital k
is greater than or equal to two then we
let
pi k be the overall probability that an
observation
is associated to the kth class
then let f k of x denote the density
function
of x for an observation that comes from
the kth class
this means that k of x is large
if the probability that an observation
from the kth class
has capital x is equal to
small x then the jesus theorem states
the equation that you see the
probability of the class
being capital k given capital
x equals to small x is the ratio
of pi k fk of x over the sum
of pi l f l of x from l
to k so for all classes
this was a bit challenging so make sure
to probably
rerun this section of the lesson because
it is very important to understand now
the challenge here
is really approximating the density
function so we will assume only one
predictor
and normal distribution this is
expressed by the function that you see
here
this is the normal distribution function
so if we plug this
function in the formula that we saw
before and take the log
we find out that we must maximize this
equation
now this is called the discriminant and
as you can see it is
a linear function with respect to x
hence the name
linear discriminant analysis
when applying lda we need to be aware of
the assumptions it makes
and make sure that it applies to our
situation here lda assumes that each
class has a normal distribution
and each class has its own mean but the
variance
is common for all classes
if you add more than one predictor which
should be the case
because usually more predictors gives
you better results
then each class is drawn from a
multivariate gaussian distribution
and each class has its own mean vector
and there is a common covariance matrix
so basically we must use vectors and
matrices
instead of single numbers compared to
lda with only one predictor
in practice this is how we apply lda
once
we initialize the logistic the linear
discriminant analysis algorithm
and then we fit it on our training data
passing the features x
and the target y then again we get the
probability with the method predict
prabha
and finally if the probability is
greater than 0.5
we say it is part of a class so we
output 1
otherwise we output 0.
now that we understand lda qda is fairly
straightforward
the main difference is in the
assumptions just like lda we assume
each class is from a multivariate normal
distribution
and that each class has its own mean
vector but this time
each class also has its own covariance
matrix
of course because we are talking about
quadratic discriminant analysis
well the discriminant here is expressed
like this and you see that the equation
is now
quadratic with respect to x since we
have two terms of x being multiplied
together now whereas lda was better than
logistic regression in some situations
qda is also better than lda mainly when
you have a large data set
because it has a lower bias and higher
variance
if your data set is small then lda
should be enough
again in python you should see some kind
of a pattern here
because as you see it is very similar to
lda and even logistic regression
so again simply initialize your model
fit it on x and y
predict the probability and if it's
greater than 0.5
output 1 otherwise the output 0.
now before we move on to the coding
portion we must understand
how to validate our models in the
context of classification
to do so we use sensitivity and
specificity
sensitivity is the true positive rate so
the proportion of actual positives
identified so for example it would be
the proportion of fraudulent
transactions that are
actually fraudulent on the other hand
specificity is the true negative rate so
the proportion of non-fraudulent
transactions
that are actually non-fraudulent
we can also use the rok curve where rock
stands for receiver operating
characteristic we usually take the area
under the curve or
auc that's why you probably hear about
the rock
auc we want the rock auc
to be close to one why well
as you can see we plot the false
positive rate against the true positive
rate
ideally we have a false positive rate of
0 and a true positive rate of 1
which would give an area under the curve
of 1
and the curve would hug the upper left
corner of the graph
as you will see soon in the coding
portion we can write a function in
python that will plot
for us the roc curve and report its area
under the curve we will actually walk
through
the plotting and the writing of this
function in the coding portion
now in the case of a perfect classifier
as i said we get an auc
of one and the rock curve should look
like this
so that's it for the theory about
classification logistic regression
lda and qda let's move on to a hands-on
example
alright so let's start off with this
project fire up your jupiter
notebooks are i have already mine open
uh as always i have this folder called
data in which i put my
data set called mushrooms.csv
the link for the dataset is in the
description of the video
so in this project we are going to
classify mushrooms as either
being edible or poisonous depending on
different features
so you have cap shape cap surface cap
collar
etc and i put all the possible values
here at the beginning of the notebook so
let's start off by importing the
libraries we're going to use open spd
known by snp of course
matplotlib.pipeplot
as plt and also seaborn
as sns
now we are going to import sklearn
the pre-processing and specifically
label encoder you will see how that will
be used
later on also from sklearn.model
selection
import train test
split with underscores and also cross
val score awesome
from sklearn.metrics we are
going to import the raw curve
and the auc as well as the confusion
matrix shift enter oh
sorry first we're gonna put the
matplotlib in line so we can see
our plots all right so shift enter
and now i am just going to um
to define a path for my data set
so data slash mushrooms with an
s dot csv and now i'm just going to
display the first five rows
of the data set
all right so as you can see these are
our first five rows we see the class
poisonous are edible and then we see the
values for each
feature so now i'm just going to do a
plot to see how many
poisonous and edible mushrooms we have
in our data set
so this will help us see if the data set
is balanced or not
so for that i'm going to use seaborn and
as you can see
our data set is fairly balanced we
almost have the same amount of poisonous
and edible mushrooms
so that is very good we're not going to
have to do a lot of preprocessing
for our analysis
now i'm going to define a function that
will allow us to see
depending on what feature how many
uh mushrooms are poisonous or edible so
for example
if i if i plot for the cap surface
so for all possibilities of values for
the capped surface i want to know
how many of those mushrooms are edible
and how many of those
are poisonous so that's going to give us
a bit of intuition
as to which feature helps you to
actually classify your mushrooms
and that's it so that's the function now
i'm going to show you how you can use
this function
but i am not going to run it because
this will actually run for all the
features of the data set so it's going
to generate a lot
of plots so i'm just going to show you
how to use it and you can run it on your
notebook if you want so you set the hue
equal to data
class so that means that you're going to
have two colors right so
one for poisonous one for edible and
then you simply want to drop
the class column and then plot
the rest of the data so
to do that you just do plot data and
then you pass in the hue
and data to plot so fairly simple
very straightforward like i said you can
run this function on your own notebook
if you want
to see uh the examples but i will not
run it
for now so let's move on to
preprocessing so you can do this by
doing escape 2 by the way
and shift enter so now i'm going to
check how many
null values do we have in our data sets
because we do not want
any anti-values so if we're calling
data.columns i want to print
the name of the column and then the sum
of null values if they are null so you
do that by data
call is dot sum
if you run it that is amazing as you can
see we have
zero everywhere so that means that we
have no null values in our data set
that's perfect
now we are going to use the label
encoder so what label encoder will do
is that it will transform our class
column into one and zeros because we
cannot work with letters we have to work
with numbers
right so you do le.fee fit transform
data class and now i will show you the
result data head
and there you go now the you you as you
can see the class is now one
and zero so either it is poisonous
or not poisonous so one being true zero
being
false then you want to one hot encode
the rest of the data set
so to do that we do pd.get dummies
and then you pass in the data so let's
see what the result of that will be
and as you can see now we have added a
lot of columns so we went from 23
columns to 118
columns because now for every feature we
have either true
or false and now that is perfect this
data is ready to be worked with because
we have only
numbers everywhere
so let's move on to modeling
first i'm gonna determine uh what the
target variable
is so in this case it is the class
uh the values.reshape minus one one
perfect and then
the features is going to be the encoded
data the head dot
sorry dot drop the class column
axis equals to 1 to make sure that we
drop the column
and then we're going to define a train
and test
set so we do x strain x test y train y
test
is going to be equal to the train test
split that we imported earlier
so you pass in your features you pass in
your target variable
and then you define the size in this
case i'm going to do 0.2 so 20
of the data set will be randomly uh
removed
to to use as a test set and we're going
to use the rest to train
you can set a random state by the way to
keep the results constant
so let's apply logistic regression our
first algorithm for
classification so from sklearn dot
linear model import logistic
regression
now we're going to initialize the model
so logistic regress
reg sorry is going to be equal to
logistic regression
now i will fit the model to our train
set so pass in x-strain and y-train dot
ravel
now we want to get the probabilities so
y prob is going to be equal to logistic
reg dot predict
underscore probably and we're going to
use the
test set in this in this case because we
fit before and now we are
doing probabilities on the test set
right
and now we set our threshold to 0.5 so
the actual prediction
is going to be np dot where so
in this case if the prediction is
greater than 0.5
we're going to say it's equal to 1 and
otherwise it's going to be equal to
zero so this is really where we are
classifying our mushrooms
so we have run that and everything is
okay you can safely ignore the warning
on the screen
and now we're going to see at a
confusion matrix so the confusion matrix
is actually going to show you
uh how many mushrooms were correctly
classified so confusion matrix
you pass in white test and you pass in
the
white prediction and hopefully if those
are equal
you will see that we're going to have a
diagonal matrix
and that is actually amazing we have
a diagonal matrix so all poisonous and
all edible mushrooms were correctly
identified
so let's check that with actually
another metric
we're going to use here the false
positive rate
and the true positive
rate as well as the thresholds
and we're going to set that equal to the
rock
curve pass in
y test and y prob
and then the rocket you see simply going
to be equal to the auc
and then you pass in the false positive
rate
and the true positive rate
so here we are actually uh going to use
the rock
curve and as you can see when we
calculate the rocket you see we get
one which is again perfect
classification
now i'm just going to define a function
to plot
the rock curve so we can visualize it
see how it looks
so this function is going to take in the
rock auc and here i'm just
basically building the plot itself so
i'm just
setting the fix the figure size to seven
by seven
i'm setting the title to uh receiver
operating characteristic
then i am actually going to plot the
false positive rate
and the true positive rate
and i'm going to give it a different
color here i'm going to use
red we're going to give it a label
called auc
and i'm only also going to approximate
the the auc basically so this is going
to give us
approximated to the two decimal places
and then i'm going to give it a legend
i'm going to put it on the lower right
side of the plot
now i am also going to plot a straight
line
going through 0 and 1. this just serves
us as a
general guide to evaluate the rock
curve and i'm going to make this line
dashed
now i am going to define the axis
or plt axis
tight
give some labels so the y label is the
true positive rate and the x label will
be the
false positive rate
and that's it for our function so let's
actually plot
the rock curve that we obtained
above with logistic regression
and you should get the following so this
is actually a perf
perfect rock curve so it's hugging the
upper left corner
and we have an auc of one so that means
perfect classification
so now let's move on to our second
algorithm which is
linear discriminant analysis and let's
see if the results are going to be
different of course it cannot be better
right
so from sklearn dot discriminant
analysis you are going to import
linear discriminant analysis
now feel free to pause the video and try
it on your own because we are going to
basically repeat the same steps as above
only this time we are using a different
algorithm
so you can always pause the video and
try it on your own as an exercise
so lda is going to be equal to linear
discriminant analysis so here i'm
initializing the model
then i'm going to fit the model with our
train
set so pass in stream and ytrain.gravel
then i am going to get the probabilities
from the lda model
so lea dot predict prabha
and you pass in x test
and then you get the predictions and we
use the same threshold as
before 0.5 so
it's actually going to be the y pro np
dot where
um y probe
there we go if it's greater than 0.5
we're just
going to classify it as 1 and otherwise
it will be 0.
run this cell and awesome everything
went well as again
again you can ignore the warning on the
screen
so we're going to build a confusion
matrix here
so white test and
y print lda
and let's display the confusion matrix
and as you can see perfect
classification again so
as an exercise we will still build the
rock curve
and show it uh simply to make sure that
we get a rock of
rock auc of one
so get the false positive rate true
positive rate and
thresholds to be equal to rock curve
passing y tests and bison the y
uh probabilities here in this case
y prob lda
now display the rock auc of
lda so first you assign it
false positive very true positive rate
and now we are
ready to display it so rock a you see
lda and we should get one and as as
expected
we indeed get one
now we are going to plot the rock curve
using the function we
defined earlier and as you can see you
get the exact same
function which is again expected right
because our confusion matrix was the
same the rocket you see was the same
the plot should be the same so again lda
is a perfect classifier in this case and
finally we are going to
implement quadratic discriminant
analysis again i strongly suggest that
you pause the video
at this point and really try to repeat
the steps
that we have done before using qda
so as always we're going to import the
model from sklearn so from
sklearn.discriminant
analysis import
quadratic discriminant analysis
now you set the model so you initialize
it sorry so qda is
quadratic discriminate analysis you can
always press tab
by the way for autocomplete you fit the
model
on your train set
and then you get the probabilities
like i said the steps are exactly the
same it's just that we are using
a different model so white prob
qda is qda.predict
prabha and you use the test set of
course
and then we get our classification so
np.where
use the same threshold so if it is
greater than 0.5
classify as one otherwise it is zero
run the cell and ignore the warning
then we're going to take a look at the
confusion matrix
so let's see if we also get a perfect
classifier here with
qda so confusion matrix you pass in a y
test and
the predictions
displaying the confusion matrix as you
can see we get the exact same as before
so again qda is a perfect classifier
for our data set
now we're gonna plot the rock uh curve
and get the a
rock auc as well so just like before
false positive rate true positive rate
thresholds
is going to be equal to rock curve pass
in y test
and the y probabilities y probe
qda and then you use the false positive
rate and true positive rate
to get your rock auc
so here i'm calling it rocket you see
qda it's going to be equal to the auc
pass in false positive rate and the true
positive rate
and now you can display the rock auc of
qda
and you get one perfect as expected now
we are simply going to plot it
to make sure that it looks like the
other plots and you know that
it will and it should and
as expected uh perfect rock curve auc
of one now let's talk about resampling
and
regularization resampling and
regularization are two important steps
that can significantly improve
our model's performance and our
confidence in the model
specifically resampling helps us
validate our model and we usually do so
with cross validation regularization
is used to prevent overfitting and we
will cover both rich regression
and lasso so first let's cover
resampling methods resampling involves
repeatedly drawing samples from a
training set
and refitting the model on each sample
this allows us to gain more information
than if we were fitting the model only
once
we can also test how the model would
perform on unseen data
without collecting new data that is
important
because a model in production will have
to predict on data it has not been
trained on
cross-validation is a widely used method
for resampling
we use it to evaluate a model's
performance
and to find the best parameters for the
model there are three ways
we can do validation we can do have a
validation set
we can do a leave one out cross
validation
or we can use the method of k-fold
cross-validation
let's explore each one of them the
validation set
is the most basic approach we have a
data set
of endpoints and we randomly split the
data set
into a training set that you see in blue
and a test set
that you see in orange we fit the model
on the blue set and make predictions
using the orange set
this has some drawbacks because the test
error rate is variable depending on
which observations were in each set
since we are splitting randomly also
only a small subset of data is used for
training
when ideally we want as much data as
possible for training
so instead we could use leave one out
cross validation
or loocv in this method only one data
point
in orange is used for validation and the
rest is used for training
you repeat the process for as many times
as you have data points
so in this case n times
the error rate is approximated as the
mean of errors for each run
now this method has the benefit of
having no randomness
but it's not a viable option for very
large data sets
so now we introduce the k-fold cross
validation
this is by far the most common approach
here
we randomly split the data set into k
groups or
folds we use the blue set for training
and the orange set for validation and we
repeat the process
k times now realize that
l-o-o-c-v is a special case of k-fold
where k is simply equal to n
the number of data points usually we set
k to 5 or 10
and like i said this method is probably
the best and most widely used
in python we can perform cross
validation like this
here we see an example with linear
regression we first initialize the model
and then we can get the mean squared
error for each fold
notice that we are performing a
five-fold cross-validation
because the cv parameter is set to five
then we can get the mean of all errors
now notice that we report the negative
of the mean because the algorithm uses
the negative mean square error as a
scoring system
therefore we need to get the negative so
that we bring it back
to a positive value
now let's move on to regularization
models can sometimes overfit meaning
that they will not generalize well
and perform poorly on unseen data
this brings me to the subject of bias
variance trade-off
on the left the model has a high bias
and low variance and you see that it's
not a very good fit
on the right you see a model with high
variance
and low bias the model is overfitting
and varying a lot and we will not give
good predictions
so we want to find a middle ground and
prevent the models from
overfitting and that's why we use
regularization
it will help us decorate our model to
prevent
overfitting here we will discuss ridge
regression
and lasso note that these methods are
also called
shrinkage methods
we know that traditional linear fitting
minimizes the
rss the residual sum of squares
with ridge regression we add another
parameter to the optimization function
here we add the sum of parameters
squared with
a coefficient lambda
lambda is called a tuning parameter to
find the best value of lambda
we will use cross validation with a
range of values for lambda
the best value will be the one
minimizing the test error
with this method all predictors are kept
and note that this is also called
l2 regularization
in python to use it we first initialize
the
ridge model then the lambda parameter
is actually alpha with the library that
we use in python
in this code snippet we provide an array
of different values for alpha
going from 10 to the minus 15 to 20.
then we will use five-fold
cross-validation
to use the best value of alpha for our
model
we'll get to apply this later on during
the
project example now with lasso we also
add a new term to the optimization
function
and lasso is also called l1
regularization
here we add the sum of absolute values
of all coefficients and we still have
our tuning parameter
lambda now if lambda is large enough
some betas will go to zero meaning that
some features will disappear
and so feature selection can be done
with lasso
in python as you can see it is very
similar to what we did with ridge
only this time we initialize the lasso
algorithm so that's it for the theory
now
let's apply these methods in a project
all right let's open our jupiter
notebooks in this exercise we will
revisit a previous data set we used
for linear regression so i always have
my data folder
and we'll use the advertising.csv
dataset
so we start off by importing pandas
numpy and
matplotlib so pandas as pd
numpy as np and then
matplotlib.pyplot as
plt and of course do not forget your
jupiter magic
so that we can display our plots
in the notebook then i will set the path
to my data set and read in the data
so data slash advertising dot csv
and then you read the data set with
pandas and we will display the first
five rows
of the data set using the dataframe.head
method index call is equal to zero
data ahead and there you go the first
five rows of our
data set now let's define a function
that will allow us to plot the target
against
each feature so as you see the target
will be sales
and then we have three features tv radio
and newspaper
so i'm going to define scatterplot and
pass in feature as a parameter
now i will specify the size of the plot
to make it slightly bigger so we can see
it
clearly on the screen plt.scatter
data feature so this is the x-axis and
then on the y-axis it will always be
sales because that is our target
and i will specify the color of the
points i want them to be
black i'm going to give it an x
label so on the x axis this will be the
money spent
on whatever feature we are plotting
so it will be money spent on tv ads or
radio ads or
newspaper ads
and then i specify a label for the
y-axis
and in this case it will be our sales in
thousands of dollars
finally we simply display the plot so
now we can
run this function and pass in each
feature
so we can get a sense of how each
feature is correlated
with the target
so tv radio and newspaper and once you
run this cell
you should see three different plots
and as you can see newspaper does not
seem to be very
well correlated with sales
so now let's define our baseline
model and see how regularization will
improve it
so first i will import cross val score
so model selection import cross
underscore
val underscore score
and linear regression and these
will be used for our baseline so our
baseline model will be a very simple
multiple linear regression
so as a first step we will define our
feature vector
so in this case we are only going to
drop the sales
column
and then we will define our target which
will be sales
so data sales dot values dot reshape
minus one one perfect
now we will fit the model so first
initialize it linear regression
and then we will calculate the mscs
so we are going to use cross validation
uh
here calculate the mean squared error
and then we are going to average
those errors so you pass in the model x
y the scoring we need to use negative
mean
squared error as required by uh
this library and we do five-fold
cross-validation
so this will give us five different mean
squared errors
so then to get the mean we simply do
np dot mean of those
mses and now we will report
the average mean squared error uh bring
it back to being positive because
remember they were negative
and so we get 3.073
approximately so let's see now how
regularization can help us improve on
our
baseline
so let's try ridge regression first
regularization and then ridge regression
perfect we will need to import a grid
search
to find the optimal value for our tuning
parameter
and of course we will need to import
ridge so esky learn the model selection
import grid search cv
and from sklearn dot
linear model we are going to import
ridge simply like that
awesome so we start off by initializing
the model
as always so ridge is going to be equal
to ridge and now we will define a list
of possible values
for our tuning parameter so in this case
uh the the parameter is called alpha in
scikit-learn and now let's pass in a
bunch of values
to test and we will use cross-validation
to find out which one is the best
so we pass in one e to the minus 15
minus 10 minus 8
minus 4 minus 3 minus 2 and then we go
to 1
5 10 and 20.
feel free to use as many values as you
want but as a starting point we'll use
these ones
so now to run our five fold cross
validation
we run grid search cv we pass in the
model
and we pass in the list of parameters
the scoring will also be negative mean
squared
error so we keep this consistent with
our baseline model
and again fivefold cross validation
now we can fit the model pass in your
feature and your target that is awesome
and it's done so now we can
actually print out uh the best value for
the parameters
and we can print out as well the mean
squared error
so you can do that by finding the best
params
and then it's going to be the best um
score exactly so when we print this out
you see that the best value for alpha is
20. and
let's not forget that our scores were
negative so let's bring it back to
positive
it's 3.0722
so it is a slightly lower msc
so now let's try out lasso and see if we
get an even better
result so at this point you can try and
pause the video to work it out on your
own as the method will be very similar
to what we have done
with range so moving on
uh we're gonna initialize lasso and set
the tolerance to 0.05 so that it can
converge
in a reasonable amount of steps
let's grab our list of parameters for
alpha
because this i'm simply going to reuse
the exact same values
to test during our grid
and then we exactly reproduce what we
did with ridge
regression so lasso regressor
is going to be equal to grid search cv
you pass in your model
lasso you pass in your parameters
the scoring method will be neg mean
squared error and again we do
a cross validation of fivefold
finally we can print out the best
parameters and the best
score so this will give us the value of
alpha
that gave the lowest mean squared
error and of course you do that after
you fit the model best params
print lasso underscore regressor dot
best underscore score underscore
once we run this cell don't forget your
negative
once we run the cell there you have it
the best value for alpha is one and we
get a
mean squared error of 3.036
approximately and this is indeed the
best
score all right let's kick off this
portion about decision trees with
a bit of theory tree-based methods can
be used for both classification
and regression they involve dividing the
prediction space into a number of
regions the set of splitting rules can
be summarized in a tree
hence the name decision trees now a
single decision tree is often not better
than a linear regression logistic
regression or lea
that's why we introduce bagging random
forests and
boosting to dramatically improve our
trees
now before we move on we need to get
familiar with a bit of terminology
trees are drawn upside down the final
regions
are called leaves the point where split
occurs is called
a node and finally the segments that
connect the nodes
are called branches here is an example
of
basic decision trees with the leaves at
the bottom and then
the branches and you see the nodes where
it splits
now let's see how a regression tree
works
to create a regression tree we divide
the predicted space
into j distinct and non-overlapping
regions
then for each observation that falls in
a region
we predict the mean response value of
that region
each region is split to minimize the rss
it uses a top-down greedy approach also
called
recursive binary splitting
now why top down because all
observations are in a single region
before the split and why do we call this
greedy
that is because the best split occurs at
a particular step to make the best
prediction
at that step instead of looking ahead
and making a split that will give a
better prediction later on
now mathematically we define the pair of
half planes
like this and we seek j and s
to minimize the rss of both planes
however this may lead to overfitting and
as you can see on the right
that's why we need to sometimes prune
the trees
and use cross validation to prevent
overfitting
in python a regression tree is very
simple to implement
as you can see we import the model from
the sklearn library
we initialize it and then we fit on x
train
and y train
now let's see how a classification tree
works
it is very similar to a regression tree
but instead
we predict the most commonly occurring
class in a region
also we cannot use the rss since we are
dealing with
categories so we must minimize the
classification
error rate the classification error rate
is simply the fraction
of training observations in a region
that do not belong to the most common
class
however this is not sensitive enough for
tree growing
so instead we use the genie index which
is a measure of total variance across
all classes the gd index will be close
to 0
if the proportion is close to 0
or 1 which makes it a good measure of
node purity a similar rationale is
applied to cross
entropy which can also be used for tree
growing
now in practice we can simply import the
decision tree classifier model
initialize it and fit it on our data x
and y now that the basics are covered
let's move on to more advanced topics on
decision trees
bagging stands for bootstrap aggregation
we know that bootstrap can compute the
standard deviation of any quantity
we also know that variance is a high in
decision trees
since they are prone to overfitting so
bagging is a method to reduce variance
and improve
the performance of our algorithm
bagging involves repeatedly drawing
samples from the data set
generating b different bootstrap
training sets
once all sets are trained we get a
prediction for each set and we
average those predictions to get a final
prediction
so mathematically we expect the final
prediction like this
and so you recognize that this is simply
the mean of all
b predictions this means that we can
construct a high number of trees
that overfit but by averaging their
predictions
we effectively reduce the variance and
improve the performance
in python as you can see it is very
simple to apply bagging
we can import the bagging classifier
initialize it
and then we fit it on our data
now let's see how a random forest can
also improve the
quality of our predictions random
forests
provide an improvement over bagging by
making a small tweak that decorates the
trees
again multiple trees are grown but at
each split
only a random sample of m predictor
is a lot is chosen from all p predictors
and the split is only allowed to use one
of the
m predictors now typically m
is the square root of p
now how is that a good thing well in
bagging
if there is a strong predictor it will
likely be the top split
and all trees will therefore be similar
so variance will not be reduced
once we average all predictions with
random forest
because we force a random sample of
predictors for each split
we avoid the situation also realize that
if
m is equal to p then it is just like
bagging
again you see that applying the random
forest algorithm is very simple in
python
once imported we initialize the model
and pass in the number of trees we would
like to use
in this case we use 100 then we can fit
on x and y
finally let's cover boosting boosting
works in a similar way to bagging but
trees are grown sequentially
they use the information from previously
grown trees
this means that the algorithm learns
slowly
also the trees fit the residuals instead
of the target
so the trees will be small and will
slowly improve
the predictions there are three tuning
parameters for boosting
the number of trees b where if it is too
large then it will overfit
so use cross validation to find the
right number of trees
we have the shrinkage parameter alpha
which is a small positive number that
controls the learning rate
typically we set it to 0.01 or 0.001
and finally we have the number of splits
in each tree
which controls the complexity of the
boosted ensemble
typically a single split works best we
also call that the
interaction depth now of course i said
that those
there are three tuning parameters in
boosting usually there are more than
that
but those are the three main ones that
we can focus on
when using the algorithm to improve its
performance
in python we apply boosting like this
now in this module
the learning rate is the shrinkage
parameter
and estimators is the number of trees in
this case set to 100
and the max depth is the interaction
depth that we looked at earlier again
once the model is initialized
we fit it on our data so that's it for
the theory now
let's see how we can apply this in a
project
all right so let's get some code done i
have a notebook open here
also feel free to grab the data set in
the description and put it
in a folder called data and the data set
here
is about breast cancer so we are trying
to
identify patients with breast cancer
from a
simple blood test so we start off by
importing our usual
libraries so numpy as np we are going to
import pandas as pd
then matplotlib dot type plot
as plt we will also need
seaborn
and today we are going to use
the function plot confusion matrix as
well
this is going to be useful to evaluate
our decision trees
later on
finally you use some jupiter magic to
display your
plots in the notebook
so now let's read our data set uh i will
simply
define my data path in this case so it
is in the folder data
and the data set is called breast cancer
dot csv
then i will use pandas to read the data
so data is going to be equal to
pd.read.csv
and i pass in my datapath feel free to
use tab
at any time to autocomplete
and we will display the first five rows
of the data set and there you go
as you can see the first five rows of
our data set perfect
now we are going to check if our data
set is balanced
because we have we are in a
classification problem so i want to make
sure that
we don't have too much of healthy
patients or
patients with breast cancer in the
dataset that would make it
imbalance so we use the count plot and
as you can see the classes are fairly
balanced here so we do not need to know
to do some crazy manipulations in this
case
now it will be interesting to uh define
a function to make violin plots that
will allow us to see
the distribution of each feature for
both classes
so it can give us some intuition about
the data so for example maybe we will
see that
most of the healthy controls are younger
so defining the function we will need x
y and data as
parameters and then i will enumerate
each y so we will define
a figure
then i will set some parameters in this
case i will i am simply setting the uh
figure size i want it to be
fairly large for you guys to see so i
will set it to
11.7 and
uh 8.27 i know i am
very precise and then you will simply do
a violin plot for each one so sns.violin
plot
x is equal to x y is the colon and data
is equal to
data that is perfect
so now in this case uh the y is actually
going to be data dot columns uh
everything but the last column so i want
so in this case the features are
actually going to be y and
x is going to be the target variable
because i want to get the distribution
of each feature for each class
now we can run the function actually
passing in
our x y and data
and you get the following plots so feel
free to
study those plots a little bit longer
and get an intuition about the data set
we are working with
now we are going to check for null
values to make sure that
nothing is missing
so for column in data dot
columns i will print
the name of the column so curly brackets
call and then we will print
the sum of null values so that is data
call dot is null dot sum
running this cell and you see that we
have no
null values in this data set that is
amazing
now we will start some pre-processing
first i would like to do
some label encoding on the target
variable so that we bring it to
one or zero so from scaling up
pre-processing import
label encoder we will initialize the
label encoder
and then we will fit transform that
on the row classification so data
classification
is le.fit transform
and you pass in data classification
now to make sure that everything is
right we'll display the first five rows
and everything is right now the healthy
control is
zero and someone with breast cancer will
have a label of
one now we will split our data set into
a training and
test set so from scalar dot model
selection we are going to import
train test split
so our target is of course the
classification
the values.reshape minus one one
and our features is gonna be everything
but
classification so i'm simply going to
drop the classification column
and i'm going to specify the axis as
well axis is equal to
1. awesome
now actually splitting our data set uh
note that our data set is fairly
small in this case so i will use a
smaller test size than we are used to in
this case i will use only 10
of it as a test uh
size so you pass in x y test size is
equal to 0.1
and a random state of 42 so that we make
sure that we get the same results
so now let's build our baseline model
so it's been our baseline model it will
be a simple decision tree
uh classifier so uh from
sklearn dot tree
we are going to import um decision tree
classifier
we will initialize the classifier so
then the brackets then we will
fit the model so call fit and then you
pass in x-train
and y-train
and finally we will plot the confusion
matrix
so the confusion matrix will show us how
many instances were misclassified
so you pass in your classifier x test
white test
and i will specify that i want uh
blue colors in this case so it's going
to be a gradient of blue
um i do not want the grid and i want to
show the plot so as you can see we get
this confusion matrix and you see that
only three instances were misclassified
in this case now i would like to show
you a cool trick because you can
visualize your decision tree
with the function plot tree so from
excalibur not tree you can import plot
tree and then let
let's see what it looks like so you're
passing the classifier and i'm going to
specify the max depth to five so we'll
only see
five different splits and there you see
it
so you can see the top split you can see
which feature was used
what what's the value of the split and
you can also check for the genie index
of each region so that is pretty cool
feel free to you know not even pass in
max that so you can visualize
the entire decision tree if you want to
so now let's try and improve on our
baseline model and
we will use bagging first
so from sklearn dot ensemble we are
going to import
um bagging classifier
we initialize the model as always so
bagging
clf is bagging classifier then we
fit the model so that fit
pass in your x train and y train
in this case you need to do dot
ravel
and now we will plot the confusion
matrix
you pass in your classifier pass in
x-test
y-test and again i will specify gradient
of
blues to keep the plots consistent
in the entire notebook
i will remove the grid and
show the plot
and as you can see we only have one
misclassified instance
in this case so bagging is an
improvement over our baseline
now let's see how we can implement
random forest at this point feel free to
pause the video and try it on your own
as the process will be very similar
uh to bagging so to what we've done uh
above
so from sklearn.ensemble we're gonna
import random forest classifier
we initialize uh the model so random clf
is going to be equal to random
first classifier and in this case i will
specify the number of trees i want a
hundred trees
then we fit the model we pass in our
train test our train
set sorry extreme and white train
and then we will plot the confusion
matrix so i'll just grab this code right
here
copy paste it down and then all i have
to do is
replace bagging clf with uh random
forest
cliff and i forgot to
to ravel the right train sorry about
that
so i trained unravel and there you have
it we have actually a perfect classifier
with
no instances that were misclassified
that is pretty great however keep in
mind this is a small data set
it doesn't mean that our model is
necessarily very good
at this point and finally we're going to
implement boosting
so uh from sklearn
dot ensembl we're going to import
gradient boosting classifier
gradient boosting classifier
so as we have done before we initialize
the model
then we fit it
so boost clf dot fit x train
and y train and then we will
plot the confusion matrix so grabbing
the code again
copy paste it below
and remove a random clf and
paste boost clf instead and again i
forgot the ravel
sorry about that guys my train dot ravel
and then you get this following
confusion matrix
where only one instance is misclassified
which is
not better than random forest but better
than our baseline
alright let's cover some theory about
support
vector machine for classification we
have seen quite a few algorithms
such as logistic regression lda qda and
decision trees
support vector machine is another
algorithm used for classification
its main advantage is that it can
accommodate non-linear boundaries
between classes
to understand svm we must first
understand the
maximum margin classifier like i said
the maximum margin classifier is the
basic algorithm from which
svm extends it relies on separating
different classes
using a hyperplane in a p-dimensional
space
a hyperplane is defined as a flat athene
subspace
of dimension p minus 1. therefore in a
2d
space the hyperplane will be a line and
in a 3d space
the hyperplane will be a flat plane
the equation for a hyperplane is defined
like this where p
is the number of dimensions now here is
an example of a hyperplane in 2d
which is represented by the line
if an observation satisfies the equation
we just saw earlier
then the point is on the line otherwise
it is above or below the hyperplane
now realize that if data can be
separated perfectly
then there is an infinite number of
hyperplanes but we only just want
one so that's why we use the maximum
margin hyperplane
or the optimal separating hyperplane
to find it to do so we must calculate
the perpendicular distance between each
training point
and the hyperplane that distance is
called
the margin then the optimal separating
hyperplane will be the one with the
largest margin
here you see an example of a maximum
margin hyperplane
and you see the margin illustrated by
the arrows
notice that the plane depends only on
the closest points
known as support vectors and if those
points move
then the hyperplane will move
but what if there is no clear separation
between the classes
as shown here well that's when svm
is required as i mentioned svm is simply
an extension of the maximal margin
classifier
this time it uses kernels to enlarge the
feature space and accommodate for
non-linear boundaries
between classes a kernel is simply a
function that quantifies the similarity
of two observations
the kernel can be a function of any
degree but of course
if the degree is greater than one then
we add more flexibility to the boundary
here is an example that we will
implement later on during the coding
portion of this
section here the classes can be linearly
separated
so it's easy enough however notice the
outlier on the left
and we can use regularization to account
for it or not
and we'll see how that impacts the model
here is another example that we will
code and as you can see here the
boundary is definitely
not linear but svm does a pretty good
job
at finding a boundary and separating
each class
so that's it for the theory now let's
move on to the coding project
and generate those plots ourselves
all right so prepare your notebooks and
grab the data from the link in the
description
in this tutorial we're actually going to
import
five different data sets so you can see
me i'm checking them right now so
x6 data one two three and then spam test
and spamtrain.mat
so as always we start off by importing
all the libraries
that we will need throughout this
project
by the way these exercises are taken
from the machine learning course by
andrew angie
i am simply solving them using python
here
by the way it's an amazing course and i
will leave the link in the description
if you want to check it out
i definitely recommend it so we import
numpy pandas matplotlib.pipeplot
also matplotlib.cm and from scipy.i
will import loadmat and finally
mypluslibinline
to show our beautiful graphs
now i will simply define the path to all
my datasets
so path 1 is going to be for
x 6 data 1 dot mat
and then we'll simply do the same data
path 2
for x6 data 2 dot matt
moving on to data path 3 for
ex 6 data 3.
and i will define the path for the spam
train and test as well and we will use
those data sets at the very end of this
of the tutorial when we will build a
classifier
for spam using support vector machines
training is done now data spam test is
data
slash spam train
test sorry dot matt perfect
uh now we will need to write a function
to plot our data i decided to write a
helper function here because
we will be plotting quite often
so we will need x y x label y label
we'll use pause label and neg label
because this is
mostly classification right and we'll
also pass in
x min max y min and y
max and set x is equal to
none
so first we're going to set the
parameters of the plot
we're actually going to set the figure
size to make it nice and big
for you guys so you can see it clearly
on the screen
i'm going to set it to 20 and 14.
now i will specify what will be
considered as
positive so it's when the the label is
going to be equal to one
and negative is of course
when it will be equal to zero
then if axis is equal to none
which by default it is
then we're going to set axis equal to
plt.gca
then we're going to draw a scatter plot
so axis dot
scatter
pass in the positives
then you pass in the y for
the positives i will specify the
marker so i want dots so you can specify
that by putting uh
the letter o in strings then i will also
specify
a color at this point feel free to use
any color
you want
s equal to 50 and the line width will be
equal to
two and finally the label
will be the pause label because those
are the
positive data points now i will draw
another scatter plot
but for the negative samples
so it will be fairly similar to the line
that we wrote above only this time it's
going to be for negative
so nag column comma
zero and then again so you pass in the y
now so x snag colon comma 1
the marker is still going to be a dot
this time we're going to specify another
color
so that we can differentiate them easily
on the plot
so ffa 600
s will be equal to 50 the line width
will also be equal to 2
and then you set the label equal to neg
underscore label awesome
now i will set the limits on the x-axis
and then on the y-axis so of course
we'll just pass in the
x-min and x-max and then you do the same
for the y-axis so while
and then you pass in the array from
y-min to
y-max
now let's set the label for x
so set x label will be x label
simply and we'll specify the font size
i'm going to put it to 12
and you do the same thing for y label so
you set y label
pass in my label and specify the font
size as 12
as well
then we will specify the position for
the legend
so acts as a legend is a box
sorry is it b box
to anchor equal to
one comma one and fancy box
we'll put equal to true
so let's start the coding portion by
exploring the
effect of regularization on svm
and we'll start off this time with a
small regularization parameter
so first let's see what our data set
looks like
so data one is load matte the data path
number one
x will be data x and the y
will simply be data y
and now we will plot the data set
so we use our function plot data pass in
x pass in y
the label will be x and y
then the positive way label we'll simply
call it positive
the negative will call it negative
we want the plot to be from 0 to 4.2
and then from 0 to five
and i made a mistake
because it should be data one not data
all right
and you see this following plot so as
you can see the positives in dark blue
the negative is in
yellow and you see that this data set is
clearly
linearly separable and you also notice
this outlier
on the left
so now let's see um with a small
regularization parameter what will
happen to that
outlier if it will be
classified correctly or not so we start
off by importing
svm from sklearn and we'll set the
regularization parameter to 1 for now
so clf will be equal to svm.svc
the kernel will be linear because as you
can see we can use a
straight line to separate the classes c
will be equal to one
and then you specify the decision
function shape to
obr
then you fit the model on your data
and now we will plot the data as well
as the boundary
so here actually we can just
grab this line from the previous cell
because it will be exactly the same
we're just plotting
the same data again and now we'll plot
the boundary on top of this data
sorry i accidentally ran this cell
but now let's actually plot uh the
boundary
or the hyperplane
so we start off by specifying x1 and x2
to be a numpy dot mesh grid
and then we pass in np arrange so we
want
from 0 to five
and from with the steps of 0.01
and np range oh
sorry this should not be here this
should be inside
the big bracket of mesh grid so np range
from 0 to 5 as well with steps of 0.01
so i'm taking small steps here to make
sure that we plot
um a smooth hyperplane as smooth as
possible
then zed will be the prediction pass
in np dot c underscore
x underscore one dot ravel
and do the same with x2 dot ravel
then zed is going to be equal to z dot
reshape
x1 dot shape
and now we are ready to plot the
hyperplane
so plt.contour you pass in x underscore
one
x underscore two pass in
zed pass in
uh zero comma five
and the colors will be uh black
so b and there is a mistake we have a
warning here no contour levels were
found within the data
uh range and that is
because okay here's the mistake
shouldn't be a comma
it should be a point so 0.5 perfect
and you see this spot here with our
hyperplane which is a straight line
in blue and we have and you can see here
that
the outlier was not taken into account
and is in this case
misclassified
so now let's see what happens if the
parameter is
very high so feel free to pause the
video
and try it on your own as an exercise
because the code will be
very similar to the previous cell
so here we are going to use a large
regularization parameter we'll set it to
c
equal to 100 and actually i simply gonna
grab
everything from this cell here and just
copy paste it below because the code is
exactly the same we are simply changing
the value of the hyper parameter so we
don't need to import
svm again and we'll simply use c
equal to 100 and see what happens next
so as you can see now the hyperplane
shifted to account for the outlier
but in this case we are likely
overfitting which means that the model
will not generalize well
so ideally we will go with the previous
model
that we built so now let's try
an example with a non-linear boundary
so svm with non-linear boundary
so for that we'll need our second data
set
so data2 is load matte data path
underscore 2 and like before we'll
specify the x and y
and plot our data set so x2 will be
data 2 x y2 will be data 2
y
and now we will use our helper function
to plot
the data so pass in x2 and y2
again the label will be simply x and y
for the class labels we'll simply use
positive
and negative and now we will set
the limits on the x-axis so zero
to one and on the y-axis it's going to
go from 0.38
to 1. and there you go
so as you can see now clearly a
non-linear boundary but the classes
seem to be separable so let's see
how svm will be able to do that
for this example we will use a radial
basis function for the kernel
here we must define gamma which is a
parameter that specifies how far the
influence of a data point reaches
a low value means very far and a high
value means
close and you can express gamma
in function of sigma
so let's define sigma as being equal to
0.1
and then gamma will simply be 1 over
2 sigma squared
so one over
open brackets two times sigma
star star squared perfect
then our classifier will be equal to
svm.svc
we pass in the kernel and this time is
going to be equal to rbf
so for radial basis function gamma will
be equal to gamma
we set the regularization parameter to 1
and the decision function shape will
again be equal to
ovr
next we fit the classifier to
our data so x underscore 2
and y underscore 2 not revel
then we will plot the data set so again
just grab this line from the previous
cell
and paste it under because we are simply
plotting the same
scatter plot as before and now we will
plot the uh hyperplane so the actual
boundary
from uh the svm algorithm
so again as before x underscore one x
underscore two
will be a mesh grid you range from 0 to
1
with bounds of width steps sorry of 0.03
so here the steps are going to be
slightly smaller because we are drawing
a non-linear boundary and again it's
just to make it as smooth as possible
and from 0.38 to 1 for y
then z will be equal to the prediction
pass in np dot c underscore
this is actually just to stack uh the
predictions
by the way so x underscore one dot ravel
x underscore 2. ravel
then we will reshape zed so that don't
reshape
we'll take the shape of x one so x
underscore one dot
shape
and now we are ready to plot the
hyperplane
so plt.contour pass in x1
pass in x2
0.5 and then colors will be equal to
blue and now there is a
big mistake input z must be 2d
and easy enough i forgot to pass in z so
x1 x2
z and then the array 0.5 color is equal
to blue
and there you have it we can see in blue
the
uh boundary that svm uh predicted for us
and you see he's doing a pretty decent
job at separating everything you see you
have a few points misclassified here and
there
but otherwise a good non-linear boundary
but now let's explore a situation where
the data is not
easily separable so for that we'll
explore the
third data set so load matte data path
underscore three
as before x uh sorry about that
x underscore three will be equal to data
three x y underscore three will be equal
to data three
y and now we will plot the data
using our helper function so plot data
we pass in x3 y3
the labels will be the same so x and y
positive and negative for
the labels
and we want to plot from minus 0.55 to
0.35
and from minus 0.8 to 0.6
so that makes the data points nice and
centered and as you can see now there is
a clear
overlap between both classes so there is
no clear boundary
between each class so this is when we
need to use cross validation in order to
find the best parameters
for the best boundary
so i will specify a list of possible
values
for sigma so we'll go from zero point
zero one
point zero three point one point three
one three 10 and
30 and we'll do the same for the
regularization parameter
c so the same values 0.01.03
0.1.3
and then 1 3 10
and 30. perfect
now i will initialize an empty list of
errors and a limited list
for sigma and c
so for each value in sigma
and then for each value for c
we will define a classifier and we will
fit it so clf
is going to be equal to svm.svc the
kernel
will be rbf again because
the boundary is likely non-linear
gamma will be equal to uh
1 over 2 times each
squared
and then after two brackets we pass in
the value for c
which is going to be each underscore c
and the decision function
shape will be equal to ovr
perfect then we will fit it to our data
so x underscore three y underscore three
unravel
and we will append uh the errors
to our list we defined earlier so we're
going to span clf.score
on data 3 x
val and data three
y vowel
dot ravel
and then we're going to append to sigma
c
the value for sigma and for
c as a tuple now running this
i have a mistake that's because
singa should actually be sigma
and i still wrote simga at the very end
yeah right here simga c is actually
sigma c
perfect so the loop red it is finished
so now we can see
uh what value for uh c and for sigma
is the best so index will be np.r
max pass in errors
sigma max and c max will be equal to
sigma underscore c
at that index
and now we can print out the values
so the optimal value
of sigma is
colon squiggly brackets sigma
underscore max and we'll print the
optimal value for c
as well
and as you can see we get an optimal
value of 0.1 for sigma
and 1 for c so now we can fit an svm
algorithm
so we set sigma equal to 0.1 gamma
is going to be equal to 1 over 2 times
sigma squared
then we will pass in those parameters to
our classifier
so the optimal classifier is
svn.svc the kernel will be
rbf
gamma is equal to gamma
c is equal to 1 and the decision
function shape
is ovr
now we will fit our classifier to our
data
so x underscore three minus score three
unravel
then we will plot the data so again just
go back up let's grab
this line here and paste it
back in our current cell
and as before we will now
find the points for the boundary and we
will plot it so x1 and x2
is np.mesh grid pass in
np range from
negative 0.6 to 0.4 and we'll take steps
of 0.004
to make it smooth and np range
from negative 0.8
to 0.6 in steps of
0.004 that is then going to be the
optimal
clf dot predict
and we will stack the prediction so np
dot c underscore
you pass in x underscore one dot ravel
and x underscore two the unravel
reshape z z dot reshape
is x underscore one
dot shape and now we will plot
the boundary so plt on contour
pass in x1 pass in x2
pass in z 0.5 in brackets and the color
will be blue and the mistake again here
is i wrote
symga instead of sigma very sorry about
that guys hopefully
we're not making the same mistakes as i
am and as you can see here we have
our best boundary found from cross
validation
with support vector machine so it's
actually not that bad
and finally let's use svm for spam
classification for our
emails right so spam train we're simply
going to load
the data set called data path
and i called it spam train
then spam test will be equal to load mat
and you pass in
data spam test
we will set the regularization parameter
to 0.1
and then x train will be
spam train and we pass in x
y train will be spam train
and we want the column y
then x test will be spam test
pass in x y test will be
spam test passing y
our classifier so clf underscore spam
will be again svm.svc
we will start with a linear kernel see
how that performs
so kernel is going to be linear the c
parameter
will be equal to c we set it above
and the decision function shape will be
equal to
ovr
then we fit our classifier to the
train set so we pass in x-strain and
y-train
unravel
and then we will calculate the accuracy
so clf underscore spam dot score
and we will score against spam train
x and spam train
y that ravel
and then we will test for the test
accuracy
so again cliff underscore spam dot
score and you pass in uh
x test and y test
dot revel
finally we will print out those scores
so the training accuracy
squiggly brackets pass in train
underscore
acc times 100
so we have it as a percentage already
and we do the same for the test accuracy
running everything uh we have a key
error for
x yes that's because here it should be x
test
and y test sorry about this little
mistake
so if we run this cell now our model
is training and fitting
and you get a training accuracy of 99.8
percent
and a test accuracy of 98.9
which is very good moving on now to
unsupervised learning let's cover some
theory unsupervised learning is a set
of statistical tools for scenarios in
which we have
features but no targets
this means that we cannot make
predictions instead we are interested in
finding a way to visualize data
or discovering a subgroup of similar
observations
unsupervised tends to be a bit more
challenging because the analysis is
subjective
also it's hard to assess if the results
are good or bad since there is no true
answer
in this section we will mainly focus on
two techniques
which are principal component analysis
or pca
and we will take a look at clustering
algorithms
let's cover pca first pca is a process
by which
principal components are computed and
used to better understand data
they can also be used for visualizations
now what is a principal component well
suppose you want to visualize
n observations on a set of p features
you could do a 2d plot
for each two features at a time but
that's not very efficient
and unrealistic if p is very large
with pca you can find a low dimensional
representation of the data set
that contains as much of the variance as
possible
that means that you will only consider
the most interesting features
since they account for the majority of
the variants
and therefore a principal component is
simply the normanized
linear combination of a feature that has
the largest variance
you see the equation here and that
should remind you a bit of linear
regression
also this equation is for the first
component
the next one will be in a direction
perpendicular to the first one
and the third component would be
perpendicular to the first two
principal components in this equation
here
phi is referred to as the loadings
here's an example of how you can apply
pca in
python in this case actually we are
trying to visualize the iris
data set in 2d this is something that we
will
apply later on during the coding portion
so this data set contains more than two
features
for each species of iris so using this
snippet we can initialize pca
and then specify that we only want the
first two principal
components and then you can see here
that we can
uh find the explained variance ratio
and then use that to plot a
2d figure of the features of this data
set
which is what you see here so as you can
see we can plot the transformed data
and see how each species of iris are
different or
separable from one another so that's it
for pca now let's take a look at
clustering
methods clustering is a set of
techniques for finding
subgroups or clusters in a data set
this helps us to partition the data into
observations that are similar to one
another
an application of that is for example
for market segmentation
in the context of marketing we will
first explore key means clustering
which partitions data in a specified
number of k
clusters and we will also look at
hierarchical clustering
which does not need a specific number of
clusters instead we can generate a
dendrogram
and see the clusters for all possible
number of clusters
but first let's focus on k-means
this method simply separates the
observations into k
clusters and we must provide that number
it assumes that each observation belongs
to at least
one of the k clusters and that the
clusters do not overlap
it is important to note that the
variation within each cluster
is minimized here you can see an example
of how the number of clusters will
affect
how the data is partitioned feel free to
pause the video if you want to study
this
a little bit longer now clustering is
achieved by minimizing the sum
of the squared euclidean distance
between each observation in a cluster
you can see the equation here of the
euclidean distance
and we wish to minimize it to do so the
algorithm first starts by
randomly assigning each observation to a
cluster
then for each cluster a centroid is
computed which is a vector representing
the mean
of the features in the cluster then each
observation is assigned to the cluster
whose centroid is the closest the two
steps above are repeated
until the cluster assignment stops
changing
now note that k-means will find a local
minimum
therefore it highly depends on the
initial cluster assignment
so make sure to run the algorithm
multiple times to see if you always get
the same results in the coding section
of the tutorial we will use k-means
clustering to perform
color quantization more on that later on
this process allows us to take a picture
and reduce the number of colors
so in this code snippet here we specify
that we want only 64 colors
in the picture then we can apply the
algorithm on the image
and output a modified image with only 64
colors
the output will look like this of course
because we use k-means we can specify
any number of clusters
to group the most similar colors
together so in this case we use 64
but later on in the coding portion we
can use 10 28
whatever number we want
now let's take a look at hierarchical
clustering
as i mentioned the potential
disadvantage of k-means is that you must
specify the number of clusters
and sometimes you simply don't know how
many clusters you need
this is when hierarchical clustering
comes in because you do not need to
specify the number of clusters
the most common type of hierarchical
clustering is called
agglomerative clustering it generates a
dendrogram from the leaves
and the clusters are combined into
larger clusters
up to the trunk here is an example
of gender grams we see the individual
observations at the bottom
and they are combined into larger
clusters as you move up
in the y-axis
the algorithm is fairly easy to
understand it starts by defining a
dissimilarity measure between each pair
of observations
and it assumes that each observation
pertains to its own cluster
note that in this case the dissimilarity
measure is usually
the euclidean distance then
the two most similar clusters are
combined so that there are n
minus one clusters the next two are
combined resulting in
n minus two clusters and that is
repeated until
all observations fall in one big cluster
now although simple how do we define the
similarity measure
well that depends on the type of linkage
and there are four
types complete single average
and centroid complete is
also called maximal inter-cluster
dissimilarity
so it computes the pairwise the
similarities in clusters
a and b and it records the largest one
with single it's the opposite and we
talk about the minimal
inter-cluster dissimilarity so here the
smallest
of the dissimilarities is recorded and
this can mean that single observations
are fused one at a time
then we have average as the name
suggests the average of the pairwise
dissimilarities
is recorded and finally we have
centroid which computes the
dissimilarity between the centroids
of cluster a and b this is sometimes a
problem
as smaller clusters can be more similar
to a larger one
than to their individual clusters which
can lead to inversions
in your dendrogram complete average and
centroid are definitely the most popular
types of linkage
note that the final dendrogram highly
depends on the type of linkage you
select
as you can see here average and complete
are
quite similar to one another but with
single leakage the dendrogram is quite
unbalanced and that's why this method
is not used often so that's it for the
theory
now let's get coding
let's apply what we learned in python
now these exercises
are available as examples on the sklearn
website i am simply reworking them a bit
or explaining them here
the links are in the description and the
complete notebook on github is also in
the description down below
so we'll start off by importing some
libraries we will need numpy
we will also need matplotlib.pyplot
as plt and finally
from sklearn.utils we will import
shuffle so let's kick off this tutorial
with
a clustering we will do color
quantization with k-means
which is a technique to reduce the
number of colors of an image
while keeping the integrity of the image
so to do that we will learn we will need
from sklearn.datasets
import load underscore sample underscore
image
and from sklearn dot cluster we will
import k-means
now after importing our libraries we
will load the image of a flower
so the flower will be equal to load
sample image
and we will pass in the name of the
image in this case it is
flower dot jpeg
now we need to convert to floats and
divide by 255
because colors are expressed as rgb
right red green and blue
with values from 0 to 255
so we need to normalize that so that the
image displays correctly with matplotlib
so this is what we are doing here so we
convert two floats and we divide by 255
to normalize everything
finally we can show the image with
plt.mshow
and we pass in flower
now i have made a mistake here uh the
name
np is not defined that's because i did
not import numpy as np
sorry about that so after re-running
this cell
and re-running this cell here we finally
get
the picture of our flower and this is
what you should get
now we will change the image to a 2d
matrix
so width height and depth will be equal
to
original shape which is tuple of flower
dot shape here uh d is the depth
will be three uh because as i
as i explained the earlier each layer
will correspond to
either red green or blue so
three values in this case and now we
reshape it
so image array is equal to np dot
reshape
flower and then we'll reshape with the
width times the height
and the other dimension will be the
depth awesome
now we will reduce the number of colors
to 64
by running the k-means algorithm where k
will be set to
64.
so our image sample will be equal to
shuffle the image array
we'll give it a random state equal to 42
so that the
uh results are constant whenever we
rerun the cell and we'll take the first
1000
samples
now we will fit the k-means algorithm
and we set here the number of colors as
i said this will be equal to
64. then k means
will be equal to k means we initialize
the model we pass in the number of
clusters
which is the same as the number of
colors in this case
and again the random state equal to 42
because as you know from
the theory part um k-means starts by
randomly assigning
uh each observation to a cluster so we
keep the random state
equal to 42 to give the same results
every time and then we simply fit
the algorithm
then we get the indices for each color
for the full image
that will be useful when we need to
reconstruct the image right
so each pixel in the 2d array will be
assigned to a certain cluster
and that will help us to bring back the
color and rebuild the image
so it's simply the labels which is the
prediction from the k-means
now we need to write a function to
rebuild the image
so like i said each pixel is assigned to
a cluster which corresponds to
a specific color
so we define reconstruct underscore
image and we will need as parameters
the cluster centers we'll need the
labels
and we pass in the width and the height
of the picture
so d will be equal to the cluster
centers
dot shape and we take d
at index one
then the image will be simply an array
of zeros
in this case and the shape will of
course be the width
the height and the depth
the label index will start at zero
and then for i in the range of the width
and for j in the range the height
we write that image
at index i j so this is the coordinates
in the 2d matrix will be equal to
the cluster centers
at labels and that itself will be
at the label index
and then we increment the label index
so plus equal one
and finally we return the reconstructed
image
so that's it for this function now we
are ready to display both the original
image
and the reconstructed one with only 64
colors
so the first plot will be the original
image
so we'll turn off the axes and then
plt.title will be the original
image with
96 615 colors
and then we will show the original image
which
in this case is simply flower and now
our second plot
so plt.figure 2.
here we will display the reconstructed
image
so again turning off the axes
the title will be
here we will write a string actually
while passing a parameter in this string
so reconstructed
image with
n colors because you can change the
number of colors we will do that
after
and then we show the reconstructed image
so in here
in there we will pass in our function we
construct image
and you pass in k-means dot
cluster underscore
centers underscore
pass in also the labels and you pass in
the width and the height
that we defined earlier
and you get the following result so as
you can see the integrity of the image
is
kept actually the flower itself is very
similar i would say that only the
background is very different
so let's go above and change the number
of colors just for fun so let's say we
want only four colors
so we're running these cells um
as you can see now with four colors the
image is very different but you can see
it's almost like a
an artistic effect that you can play
around with so feel free to play around
with this number of colors with yourself
now let's work with pca for
dimensionality
reduction
here we will work with the iris data set
this data set has four features
about three different kinds of iris
flowers
and our goal is to visualize the data
set in two dimensions
so from sqlearn.datasets we'll import
load iris
and from masculine decomposition import
pca
now let's load the iris dataset so iris
will be equal to load
iris the features is iris.data
the target is iris dot target
and then the labels or target names
here is iris dot target
underscore names awesome
now let's initialize the pca algorithm
and we will specify that we want only
the first two principal components
since we want a 2d plot
then x underscore r is pca dot
fit x dot transform
x
now let's actually print out the amount
of variance that is explained
by each principal component
so the explained variance ratio
from pca
and you can extract this information
from
the pca object itself so it's pca dot
explained underscore
variance underscore ratio underscore
running this cell as you can see the
first principal component explains
92 percent of the variance and the
second one 5
so that means that a total of 97 of the
variance
is explained with only two components
so now we are ready to plot our data set
in 2d
and that data that newly transformed
data
contains about 97 of the variance of the
original
data set so here we'll just specify
three different colors
to distinguish between the three
different kind of iris flowers
so the final one will be ffa 600
and we'll set the line width equal to 2.
then plt.figure
and then for color in
oh sorry so for color i
target name in zip
and we pass in colors we will
pass in uh zero
one and two and we pass in the target
names so 0 1 and 2 here
are simply the the classes right
so we'll draw a scatter plot so
plt.scatter
xr
when y is equal to i
and zero and then x r
when y is equal to i
and one so this is basically the x-axis
and then the y-axis
and the color will be equal to uh
the color at this point in the loop
alpha will be equal to 0.8 and then lw
we set it equal to lw that we specified
above
finally the label will be equal to the
target name
at that specific step in the loop
now we will simply put a legend on our
plot
the location sorry the location equal
will be equal to
best
and we don't want any shadow
finally let's set a title to our plot
so pca of iris dataset
running this cell as you can see now we
get this
plot right here and so you can visualize
in two dimension a dataset that
contained
four features and three classes so
now you could follow up with some
classifier maybe decision trees on this
transform data set
to classify each kind of flower
alright so that's it for this data
science crash course
i hope that you enjoyed it and that you
learned something interesting
if you want more videos on this topic or
videos on end-to-end data science
projects
please check out my youtube channel
until next time take care